Speaker 1: Well, there's been another mass
shooting, this one at a school. This one
the deadliest school shootings since Sandy
Hook Elementary School shooting in 2012.
And, guys, this is this is not normal. Yesterday,
I did a story about how we've had 210 mass
shootings so far in 2022. And while I was doing
that segment, I noticed that a 211th shooting
had been added from Monday. So yesterday,
Tuesday morning, I recorded that segment.
And in the time from when I gathered the data to
when I recorded the segment, a monday shooting
had been added to the list. So while I was
talking, we went from 210 to 211 mass shootings.
Before that segment published yesterday, a 212th
mass shooting this year took place. Another teen
gunman at an elementary school in Uvalde, Texas,
killed his grandmother before going to school.
As of right now, 19 dead. The shooter also dead.
The shooter bought the guns legally when he turned
18. In other words, the law worked to the extent
that this was someone that got the guns legally.
And then we had this shooting. Now, of course,
it's hard to know all the details so soon after
the event. The details so far are horrifying.
For example, one new detail is all of the
deaths happened in one classroom in the school.
Imagine the carnage that we're talking about here,
even for the kids that survived unspeakable. As
always, mental illness is being brought up by the
right as the sole factor and cause here. And it's
like a broken record. But as I've said before,
the mental illness element is not an either
or. After the buffalo shooting and now as well,
we're hearing the Wright that doesn't want
to talk about guns and availability of guns.
Talk only about mental illness. It's not an either
or. Often there's a mental illness component. And
if that's what we believe, we should make
mental health treatment more accessible,
more affordable, easier to get. Just about every
Republican is against that. They will say when we
try to expand access to all health care, including
mental health coverage. These Republicans who say
the mass shootings, which are an epidemic, are
merely a mental illness problem, they say no. But
what you want to do is a government takeover of
health care. What you want to do is socialism. So
the first thing is, if they really want to deal
with this as a mental health issue, why do they
vote against every opportunity to expand access
and reduce cost of mental health care? Number two,
we have to say most mentally ill people are not
violent and never commit any violent acts nor
crimes. So sometimes there's the reaction from
some in my audience to say even mentioning mental
illness is an insult to the mentally ill. Well,
it's not about being an insult. It's just that.
Almost never do mentally ill people commit
crimes or become violent. Now for the small
percentage that does. If there are fewer guns
around, if it's more difficult to get guns
in general. Whatever violence mentally ill
people try to commit will be less lethal.
If the mentally ill people who would kill 20
with assault rifles can only get a handgun,
maybe they only kill five. If they can't even
get the handgun, maybe they can only kill one
with a knife. You get the point. Okay, so even
if we concede there's a mental illness component,
well, we should fund dealing with it. And it would
still be better if those few mentally ill people
who want to commit violence have a harder time
getting guns. At the end of the day, this is
an issue of more than one thing, number one. Too
much into easy access to guns. That's one piece.
Number two, we have a cultural problem in the
United States. In the United States. I don't
want to say it's necessarily celebrated, although
in some places it is. It's looked at as plausibly
okay by too many people in the United States that
it's okay to use firearms to solve interpersonal
or societal problems. Can't find a girl.
Well, maybe use a gun to go and do something.
Disaffected by society. Having a conflict that
work. The disgruntled employee shootings like
we saw on public transit in California. What
was it? A year ago? Six months ago. 18 months
ago. I don't even remember. So that is another
component. There's there's a real cultural issue
in the United States. And number three, there is
the element of untreated and undiagnosed mental
illness as a result of the disastrous health
care system that Republicans refuse to fix.
The same people who are saying the only problem is
mental health are the ones who consistently vote
not to expand access to mental health treatment.
There's mental health issues everywhere. It's
important to know in the United States. There's
way more guns and way more easy access to guns.
And that's a unique issue in the United
States. We also have issues with access
and cost when it comes to mental health treatment.
So there's there's violent video games everywhere.
There's mental health issues everywhere. So
when a Republican or anybody else says this is
just about mental illness. Ask what legislation
they supported to fund mental health treatment,
to make it affordable, to make it accessible. One
other thing on this. You also have to understand
the absurdity of Republican arguments about
how limiting access to guns would achieve
nothing. For years, Republicans
have been saying, if you explain
to kids how to have safe sex and you give them
access to condoms and birth control pills,
they're going to have more sex and they won't take
the birth control pills correctly or whatever. And
it's going to be more unwanted pregnancy. If you
if you do that, you're going to get more unwanted
pregnancy. They've said for years, if you have
these harm reduction, safe drug use sites, it's
going to encourage more drug use and it's going to
lead to more overdose. But then they want to say
more access to guns has no impact on gun violence.
That doesn't really make any sense. But meanwhile,
they say if you ban abortion, you'll end abortion.
Well, if that's true, why wouldn't limiting access
to guns at least reduce mass shootings? Oh, no,
no, no, no. That's different. Nothing will work
to stop this, say people in the only country where
this regularly happens. That doesn't make sense.
We've really tried nothing, but we're out of
ideas. The only thing we have is arming teachers,
which we're going to get to in a moment.
Aren't we at the point where it's worth trying
some gun safety regulations along with other
things just to see if it's work? Do what
many other countries have done with great
success and see if it works here. I mean,
parents had to provide DNA samples because their
kid's bodies were mutilated beyond recognition
to try to figure out who are these dead kids.
We can't even talk about gun safety regulations.
And now they're they're back on the armed
teachers train, which I want to talk about next